[Music]
you know what I'm going to say yes it's
that time of the month again Sony have
revealed the sixth three games we'll be
getting on PS plus for the month of June
2017 this month is bloody great if I do
say so myself with a first-person
shooter an interactive adventure a side
scroller a solid racer a ruthless
top-down shooter and a good old puzzle
game - you can get your hands on all of
these on Tuesday the 6th of June so
let's do this
as always let's start with the offerings
on the ps4 first Killing Floor 2 kicks
off the month and comes highly
recommended from Destructoid GameSpot
and IGN this game follows on from the
original killing floor in which a deadly
outbreak has created zombies known as
dead this first-person shooter can be
played alone but really excels by an
online co-op as you battle wave the dead
culminating in a good old boss fight the
boss fights are randomly selected - so
it will keep you on your toes the game
is only six months old and already
additional mods have been added namely
the player vs. player mode which was
added in April okay there isn't much
plot here to get your teeth into but if
you have a hankering for murdering
zombie hogs then this is definitely
worth your time
but if story development is more your
scene then feast your eye holes on life
is strange
our second offering on the ps4 you play
as Mac a photography students based in
Oregon okay that doesn't grab you does
it okay what if I told you she can
rewind time yes this mechanic is a
master stroke and helps life is strange
stand out from typical telltale game
stories you've probably played in the
past for example if you are unhappy with
a decision you've made in the moment
then go back in time and change your
answer the time travel mechanic goes
further than that - but I don't want to
spoil it for you so I'll shut my face
now but I will say the first episode has
so much to explain that it can feel a
bit long-winded in places but I beg you
to stick with it you will be so glad you
did
life is strange average is 85 out of 100
across all reviews I've seen are you
going to try it let me know your
thoughts below please over on the ps3
we'll see of this obviously pop up
long time ago back in 1890 a huge chasm
has opened up in a town with endless
supplies of weird and wonderful enemies
filling out pack and flush your way
through them going down deeper into the
void using fighting mechanics described
by the creators as smash bros meet
street fighter hmm that's not all so
good old procedurally generated
environments will keep the game feeling
fresh and unique the highest score I
could find for this one was eight out of
ten from Eurogamer and metacritic has
this one at 69 out of 100 game number
four is WRC 5 last year's World Rally
Championship game I'm not the greatest
person to ask about driving games as
Super Mario Kart was the pinnacle of my
racing careers it seems solid enough
please help me out here if you've played
this type of game or you know about this
theory please give us a review below is
it worth our time or should we avoid
this one like the plague over to the
Vita for our final two games which
should be available on a ps4 to neon
chrome is a run-of-the-mill top-down
twin-stick shooter which plays in a
similar vein to Smash TV if you're as
old as me or hotline Miami the
environment has many destructible
elements which makes observing your
surroundings imperative the gameplay
does feel meaty and the enemy placements
are well thought out and every five also
flaws you complete will bring you to a
boss fight twin-stick shooters play so
well on the Vita so I'll be grabbing
this one what about you game number six
is your puzzle title for the month in
which you play as a chameleon sneaking
through levels without being spotted
this one is perfect for a bus or train
journey as levels are quite short and
beating your best time can be quite
addictive you can even channel your
inner solid snake by hiding in boxes
metacritic has this one at 71% if you
don't go in expecting too much I think
you'll enjoy this one so that's it
that's our six offering for PS Plus for
June 2017 I'm extremely happy with this
month's offering especially the ps4 game
and I can't resist the charm of neon
chrome on my beloved Vita but enough
about me what are you grabbing please
let me know your thoughts and maybe
consider pushing that like button if
this video helps and come subscribe if
you haven't joined our dysfunctional
family already that is anyway I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]